right now one of the lovely things about
this is that we can check our intuition
I asked you to get your lab totes
laptops out before if you haven't done
that get your device out now
what I'd like you to pull open is desmos
now some of you no doubt will have
discovered this already but others of
you will not have just yet so once
you've got your fresh desmos open here
what I'd like you to do is up where you
enter in a function let's enter in a
function that as you know if you just
start typing some stuff it will just
start graphing okay but before we do
that I want to introduce or reintroduce
some notation we've used before this
thing we're about to draw I want to call
it f of X so if you go over to your
alphabet keyboard so in the bottom left
hand corner get away from the operations
keyboard where all the plus minus times
divide is press your ABC over the left
hand corner you get this is your alpha
medical keyboard so I mean you can call
the or function if you like but let's
just be consistent I'm gonna use f4
function so it's time f come back to
your regular keyboard here and I want to
write f of X okay so I'm gonna open a
bracket it's over there on the Left X
and then I'm going to close my bracket
now at this point des mots is wondering
what do you mean by F do you mean that
just as a constant that's why it's
asking you if you want to add a slider
we don't mean it as a concert even
though we can use this notation in the
same way I'm gonna say equals and then
could so literally what was actually the
first function that we did today because
I just covered half of it starts with 3
doesn't it 3 X to the power 5 and then -
thank you x squared or 3 there we go
okay so hopefully you've got this
mean-lookin keep you big in front of you
very nice okay all right excellent
now just underneath that we're going to
do a new function and this time and this
is the part that I was talking about
before which some of you may have
encountered just by poking around a
limit others maybe not over there in the
bottom right hand corner you see there's
a whole button that says functions see
that okay so go ahead and click on that
and you have a bunch of options here
trigonometric functions it's just two
cool functions and so on and what I want
you to do is go over to the right hand
side where it says
miscellaneous Mis see and then there
should be in the bottom right-hand
corner or almost the bottom right hand
corner and it should be a button that
looks like it might be useful in a topic
where we've been doing calculus do you
see which one I'm looking at you see the
one there it's that D on DX button right
there right what do we call this guy we
had a name for it or phrase really we
call it the differential it does things
right it it's a it's a it's going to
operate on something so we call this the
differential almost it's the operator
right I need something over here this
isn't anything by itself it's like
writing side and then there's nothing
after that you need to put something in
right what do you think we should put in
f of X right now I could just write out
3x to the 5 blah blah blah blah but the
whole point in calling this giving your
name f of X is I can now just go here
and I can type in f of X and I've got my
stuff there okay do you have this on
your screen
maybe I want to zoom in a little more
because I just picked those numbers
randomly and then it looks very useful
until you zoom in so how to think this
blue function here apparently is a
derivative now we have an answer for
this didn't we so I'm just gonna pull
this back up for Brewin over we had 15 X
to the 4 minus 2x on 3 does that very
roughly match what you expect to get out
of or just waiting for us to hold there
we go is that roughly back to what you
expect does that look like it might be
June right you've got an X to the 4 out
the front so that's why whether it
rather you put in a negative value or a
positive value you can see it's
skyrocketing just like a parabola does
this is not a problem but it's like one
ok very good
so what you got setup here is here's
some function any function you like and
then desmos will differentiate that for
you how generous okay up there at the
top let's muck around with f of X right
because you can change f of X to
anything you like and desmos will
differentiate that for you what was the
second function it was this X cubed
minus 1 business so you're gonna need to
bracket to you so let's delete this guy
here hmm
here we go start your brackets open it
up and then pop in your second function
here's what we're checking out here
what was it 2 X to the 4 and then I
think it was plus X was it is alright
how's this looking does that match what
you've got yeah okay so in this case the
red function is what we started with in
fact that's always the case here's our
red function and then here's our blue
derivative Eid here okay
yeah that's not it's not a bad
skateboard park right okay good all
right so I'm just checking does that
look like sort of what you expected
roughly you can actually what's really
great is we I said we were going to
check our answer before right and we got
an answer before it was 3x to the 6 3 X
to the 6 was it - kind of everybody - 4
X cubed minus 1 4 X cubed minus 1 so
what you can see here here's our green
what we thought was the answer now the
first thing I point out is it's kind of
close right you see it has the similar
kind of shape the blue and the green
ones similar kind of shape do you agree
it's off a little bit isn't it what does
that say to you that they don't match
what does that say to you that what that
should say to you is ok this green graph
is like our derivative but it's a little
bit off isn't it so I probably need to
go back in my algebra and check out I
think most of the right pieces are there
but something is not quite right so I'm
gonna have to go back and check my
algebra ok lovely thing that we can do
we can check right last last thing let's
go do that one in fact I don't need it
what do you think I'm gonna ask you to
put in the top X minus 1 or X plus 1
okay go ahead to label whatever function
you got up there and pop in our new one
here
yeah okay let's zoom back out all right
do you have something that looks like
this roughly you getting there no not
getting there who's got something
completely different
yeah yeah no you're happy okay all right
now I think I heard it starts with an H
that read graph the original graph what
kind of shape is that it's a hyperbola
very good it's a bit of a sorry it's a
bit of a mucked up hyperbola partly
because instead of just 1 over X we've
thrown a few extra bits and pieces in
there so that's why it's a little bit
sort of off-center and all that kind of
thing but now what importantly I'd like
you to look at is just the blue function
this derivative function the gradient
function does it match what you expect
hmm yeah well and that's totally fine by
the way we're still very early on in our
familiarity with calculus but hopefully
you can see the first thing I want to
notice about this blue function is you
see it's all above the x-axis do you see
that right so it's all above there
because the red function it's always
look at its gradient I know it changes
but look at it's great from left to
right we have a word to describe this
starts with a word letter I it's always
going up so that's what we call it
increasing functions you see that in
some places it's going up but real slow
real slow right it's hardly doing
anything but it is going up and then it
sort of takes off even down here you can
see oh this is also increasing just in a
different way so far so good and then
you can see where it's doing it slowly
or where as - you're fast okay very good
now lastly I'd like you to do is the
last thing but for now let's go back to
that original original function I'm
going to ask us to put in something that
we didn't have a look at earlier today
and then we're gonna get desmos to
differentiate it now before I introduce
this let's just mute this for a second I
want you to pay close attention to these
three functions that we thought about
here okay this had a power of five to
begin with right para five then we
differentiate and what did you get
something in the power of four very good
the proper words for these are we
started with a quintic then we ended up
with a quartic
okay with that this guy here excuse me
it starts off if you had expanded out
some of you actually did right if you
had expanded out you've got something
that started with a power of seven you
see that your X cubed and you X to the
four there so your X to the seventh and
then when you finish we agreed that this
was not the derivative it was very close
right it had to save the right overall
shape and instead of having a power of
seven we don't see you've got a power of
six right so changed one more thing when
you have a look at this right this is a
bit weird it's not a polynomial at all
right but hopefully you notice when you
differentiate it you got this weird and
unusual thing and if you want you can
pop this into DES boss and you'll see it
is in fact the same blue curve we got
before okay in other words when you take
some function any function and then you
differentiate the thing you get at the
end which tells you about the gradient
enzyme quite different doesn't it and
you sometimes you look at what desmos
gave Ian you're like well this is weird
a bit unexpected but that's it made
sense as you thought about it okay